folks I think that one of the biggest
questions I get that has the most
heartache around it on this show to the
last 25 years has been questions we have
somebody that we care about that is
wanting or needing money and we somehow
feel duty-bound or something like that
because it's family and here's the thing
you have to remember when you are giving
someone support financially who is
misbehaving you are paying them to
misbehave how is that good for them in
the long run that's like saying hey my
32 year old son has a cocaine habit and
he wants money so I'm going to go buy
him some cocaine now that's an extreme
hyperbole but it does illustrate the
point of you are financing crap that's
hurting him and when your 32 year old
son lives in the basement and plays
games electronic games on the television
all day long it won't get a job you are
not helping him you are supporting his
sloth is laziness
that's tough love Dave no that's just
love because I love my son
I don't want good things for him and
sitting in the basement playing video
games all day is not going to bring him
good things because he is not a video
game developer that is not his job no
one's paying him to do that and so he's
engaging in something that is a
adolescent at best at that level the
occasional video game is not adolescent
that's not what I'm saying
but when you sit there all day long
you're 32 in your mother's basement
that's a problem people that's called
Arrested Development stunted emotionally
hasn't grown up and so you're not loving
him well by leaving him there kick his
little butt out make him get a life let
him experience some of the stresses of
life it'd be so good for him he might
become a man instead of
boy see these are the knesset area to
salute tough-love that's my top love you
are bringing harm to your child you're
bringing harm to your relative when you
give them money to participate in their
misbehavior and if they simply just
won't work much or they won't do a
budget if they won't save money and they
continually run up credit card debt
that's all misbehavior and when you pay
someone for doing that because you're
too weak to say no you are bringing them
harm because you're reinforcing the
negative behavior you're what we call it
an abler and it's not love it's just
weakness that's all it is it's not it's
not tough though either but I'm talking
about I'm just talking about love just
do something for that relative that
friend that is good for them that's all
it matters if it's not good for them it
doesn't cause them to have a better life
at the end of the equation you haven't
done the right thing this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]